it is an extraordinary development in
this war Vladimir Putin the leader of a
U.N security Council permanent member
Nation facing an International arrest
warrant and for the most serious of war
crimes
Sky News was the first to reveal video
evidence of Russian soldiers searching a
place of sanctuary in Ukraine looking
for children this was one orphanage in
her son where orphans were abducted at
gunpoint by the Russian military
these children among thousands across
Ukraine said to have been taken by the
Russians during this war
allegations now the focus of
international criminal court arrest
warrants that go to the very top of the
Russian government their international
criminal court is issued two warrants of
arrest in the Eucharist tuition
for Vladimir Putin president of the
Russian Federation and foreign
commissioner of the Russian presidents
from children's right for the alleged
World crimes of deportation of children
from Ukrainian occupied territories into
the Russia Federation
it is forbidden by international law for
occupied powers to transfer civilians
from the territory they live in to other
territories this was Vladimir Putin
meeting his children's rights
commissioner last month the arrest
warrants against both are being welcomed
by Ukraine's president zielinski
separating children from their families
depriving them of any opportunity to
contact their relatives Hiding Children
on the territory of Russia throwing them
in remote regions all this is an obvious
State policy of Russia State decisions
and state evil which begins precisely
with the top official of this state
the warrants mean Vladimir Putin must
think very carefully about where he
travels and make the Russian leader even
more of an international Pariah the
Kremlin and its mouthpieces have reacted
with Fury my attractions
here and irresponsibility of the
international
criminal court it's the policy of
Russian government to save children not
to steal children but to save children
from the front line Zone
so what are the chances of Vladimir
Putin going from wartime leader to the
accused in an international court of law
we have to be very realistic that we're
not going to see uh Putin in The Hague
anytime soon and of course there'll be a
lot of cynicism as to whether we will
ever see him there uh of course we won't
be looking at a trial In Absentia at the
ICC the move puts Putin in the dubious
company a former Libyan leader Muammar
Gaddafi and Sudanese president Omar
al-Bashir both indicted by the ICC but
never tried Vladimir Putin may be able
to elude prosecution for now but that
doesn't mean this move doesn't have real
significance it's important because this
man is now as many would say he should
have been said to be from a couple of
weeks after the war started labeled as a
criminal
and that's going to be make it much much
more difficult for the Coalition of
countries supporting Ukraine to separate
out and to say oh we shouldn't be
carrying on with this war
next week China's president Xi Jinping
flies to Moscow for talks with Vladimir
Putin his host will be an alleged war
criminal how might that influence his
next move the answer to that could be
crucial in the next stage of this war
Dominic waghorn's Sky News